you've already learned how to move the
pieces and we've mentioned the idea of
capturing let's talk more about
capturing in chess when you capture a
piece you simply move your own piece to
the same Square as your opponent's piece
and replace their piece with your own
the captured piece is then removed from
the board you don't stop before the
captured piece you replace it entirely
let's watch this Queen capture a pawn
now let's watch this Knight jump over
one of its own pieces to capture the
Queen capturing pieces is a critical
part of the game however you do not have
to capture a piece if you don't want to
that being said if you can capture more
of your opponent's pieces and they
capture of yours it's going to be much
easier to win one question about
capturing that we have an answer it is
how do you notate a capture let's say in
this position that you plan on taking
the black queen with your queen on b3 a
good idea you would write the piece that
will capture it in this case the Queen
so we use a capital Q you then write in
X which means captures and then you
write the square where the piece gets
captured
so after Queen takes c6 we would write Q
x e6 here is one more capturing question
how do we notate a pawn capturing a rook
and promoting to a queen at the same
time
does it sound complicated don't worry
it's just one extra step
we start by notating the capture
remember we mark a pawn with the file
that it is currently on in this case the
pawn is on the B file so we would write
a lowercase B then we would write
captures which is an X so lowercase B X
and then the square that we capture a 8
so BX a 8 so far we have BX a 8 since we
are promoting to a queen
you simply add to the end of your
move-in equal sign and then write which
piece you are promoting the pawn in to
which is usually the queen so putting it
all together we would write B takes a 8
equals queen now it's your turn to
practice capturing pieces